so there's two main parts to the
University there's the research
enterprise and there's the educational
enterprise and I definitely see both
parts of it changing a lot in the next
decade or so so speaking about the
educational Enterprise it's not enough
for people to learn the skills that
they're learning today as valuable as
they may be but it's it's going to be
very important for them to learn
innovation skills that enable them to
better communicate their ideas and
communicate a value proposition figure
out how to make greater impact with
their ideas by enrolling other people in
their vision and to understand how to
finance their idea and how to turn it
into a sustainable business nonprofit
whatever form it is and so that's going
to be really important as we think it's
especially important at the phd level we
think that that's something that's been
ignored the fact that phd's in fact Kurt
Carlson who's a CEO of SR I
international there a nonprofit research
lab in Menlo Park he was who's giving a
talk recently and he where he said that
their PhD students they get they get the
most amazing PhDs around the world to
come around the country to come and work
for them and despite that it takes them
seven to ten years to become fully
productive members of the team and why
is that it's because they lack the
innovation skills they lack the skills
of understanding how they fit into the
innovation ecosystem how they fit in how
they communicate their ideas and how
they address real-world problems so
that's a perfect validation for the fact
that you USC were just announced and
we're launching for the Fall a
innovation diploma program for PhD
students that's free of charge for PhDs
it's a three course sequence unlike any
other program that we're aware of and we
think it's really really valuable for
our students to not we're not trying to
turn PhDs into business people we don't
think that's appropriate we don't think
that it always works what we want to
keep them as researchers and at the
cutting edge of their field and that's
that's their whole
goal is to become the absolute best in a
discipline and there have been some
criticisms that academics don't
understand the bigger picture or they
don't they're too specialized the
reality is if you're going to be the
absolute best you have to be very
specialized but that doesn't preclude
you from understanding how to
communicate with others that can take
your idea and make it into something
really impactful so it's sort of
bridging that gap by making both the
academics aware and then of course we'd
like to focus on the the business
community as well to bring them closer
to academia
there's a lot of changes that are
happening now that are really going to
be impacting the way innovation happens
in the University one of them for
example is open access to research
results and people are publishing
increasingly in open access journals and
in fact I think they've been about 5,000
new open access journals that have
popped up online in the last couple
years they're circumventing the typical
peer-review printed journal publications
and that's really having that will have
some significant effect I think in the
future and it's not just a matter of
open access to the papers but also
there's been a greater drive towards
open access towards the the data itself
which starts to it's somewhat
controversial because there's definitely
an interest by faculty with all the work
that they put into collecting that data
and this has been a challenge for for a
while but it's exacerbated by this new
open access is how do you get the get to
benefit from your own data that you've
worked so hard to collect and then and
publish on so how long is it appropriate
to hold back that data before you share
it with other people obviously the
sooner you get the data out there the
more people will benefit and at the same
time you need to motivate faculty to be
collecting that data in the first place
and so that's that will be an
interesting thing to see also digital
scholarship is changing the output of
research so it used to be that you can
do some research you can write it up in
a thesis or a paper publish it or put it
on a bookshelf and and that was your
publication that's not going to cut it
anymore you have digital multimedia
output that how do you archive that so
for example we have this program this
the system that was developed at USC and
collaboration with some other
universities called hyper cities it was
developed by historian in fact
at USC and Phil ethington and what it is
is you can put geo rectified maps and
geo tagged photographs into the system
and you can look at for example I can
look at my neighborhood and then click
on a button it's a it and it goes from
the view from the from the sky of
satellite view down into well let's see
what the map looked like from 1986 now
let's see this other map from 1920 and
you realize my god there's no marina
there and you can really go through it's
almost like going through time and
seeing how things were you can look at
different photographs and very much in a
crowdsourcing fashion it enables other
historians now its platform where other
people can add to this archive of
information so it brings up some
interesting questions one of the
questions is how do you how do you store
and that kind of output if it's not a
piece of paper that you can put in the
library or you can scan in how do you
archive this how do you enable people to
access that information and if you are
allowing people to contribute to it then
how do you give proper credit to those
individuals that are contributing to
this piece of scholarship if there's now
hundreds of people that are contributing
to this so this is very different a
little brave new world it's different
from the way it was say 20-30 years ago
and it's going to continue to change
it is an interesting challenge that in
order to motivate people to excel and do
things it's part of human nature that
you need to there needs to be some sort
of incentive so in the market economy
it's very much based on financial
rewards in academia it's very much based
on reputation and so either way there's
competition I do think in academia it's
much more collaborative so I think that
although people can criticize academics
at times for holding back certain
research results and it's not ideal
that's not optimal at the same time I do
think that that there is a real sense of
collaboration and the desire to have
great 22 to create great results
together but I do think that there we do
have to be collaborating more and we are
collaborating more perfect example is
the human genome project so that would
not have come together unless you had
there's many universities and
researchers that came together to work
for the greater good on this project and
ultimately it was clear who the big
contributors were it's really a part of
the whole ethic is to try to be able to
track that but there are challenges
because if you're if you're starting to
bring together lots of other people you
want to make sure that you we need to
make sure that we maintain that ethic
for providing acknowledgement to the
people who contribute we have lots of
big challenges ahead of us whether it's
trying to reduce the cost of solar
energy or trying to deliver clean water
so the whole world or you know renewable
energy in general and global warming all
of these things are going to really need
to have large collaborations and I don't
know that we've completely figured that
out yet I also think that it will cause
a bit of it is just a prediction that
will cause some pressure and some
challenge for some meat from four
universities because right now
especially the larger elite universities
they have large research enterprises
that they can
build on and they can they can build on
the reputation by bringing in more
research dollars and to be doing more
exciting research and at the same time
if universities and universities are
collaborating more on programs then the
universities will maybe be asking
themselves well how do we preserve our
brand because brand is important in that
collaboration so there needs to be the
universities as individual universities
need to have a value proposition so that
it's not just a place where faculty sit
and get a paycheck you know it's really
the because faculty can take their
research and they can move to another
place so it will put more pressure on
universities to ensure that they're
doing their jobs and creating that
environment that innovative environment
that enables people to collaborate and
work together and that's really one of
the huge values of universities and a
place like USC for example we've been
around for almost 130 years absolutely
integral to the local community and also
within our own you know we've built up
this faculty over the years and that
enables us to get the absolute best
students to come through and so it's
it's based on a real foundation and we
need to know as an example we just need
to make sure that we maintain that and
we keep growing and we keep increasing
that or else we're not going to be
relevant